[Music]
hey what is up guys I'm Kim PhD here and
you may have seen me tease or hint a
little bit on Twitter about the next two
weeks or so of mkbhd videos because they
are going to be filled with a lot of
awesome stuff
but this is the beginning of it this is
the full review of Google's chromecast
one of Google's newest products that was
announced alongside the new Nexus 7
which I also have coverage of coming up
very soon but this is the chromecast so
there's a lot of cool things about this
product it is a very simple product but
it does have a lot of implications about
the future of what Google is gonna be
focusing on but basically chromecast is
a dongle that you plug into your TV via
HDMI that turns it into a smart TV of
sorts now as a box actually says it's
the easiest way to watch online video on
your TV and I agree with that but you
can see here the focus is on the video
but it does a bit more than just video
as you'll see in a second so when you
get your chromecast you of course get
everything in this convenient little box
here and when you open it up inside on
the left are all the instructions you
need to set it up for the first time and
you only have to set it up once I got
mine done and literally about two
minutes flat
so it's pretty easy and aside from the
chromecast you get a USB cable for power
an HDMI extender if your TV's HDMI port
is a bit hard to reach and a power brick
which you only have to use if you can't
get USB power from your TV but most
newer TVs have powered USB ports anyway
so this isn't going to be a thing that
everyone needs to use the chromecast
itself is pretty small it's just a
dongle obviously the HDMI is on one side
to plug it in and USB input for power
and a small reset button on the other
side also side note chromecast and
everything inside of it is mostly based
on Android not Chrome which makes the
logo and the name of the product in the
Box a little bit misleading but whatever
that doesn't actually matter so you plug
your chromecast into the back of your
regular TV not a smart TV it doesn't
really matter you hook it up to USB
power whether that's into the wall or
into the USB port on your TV follow the
two minutes setup guide and boom you are
ready to cast so my chromecast has a
name it's called Marquez's chromecast
very clever and it's connected to my
Wi-Fi network which is called mkbhd
so now every supported device that's
also on the mkbhd network can see and
cast to this chromecast enable TV so
right now supported devices include
every Android device every iPhone every
iPad and every computer running Google
Chrome thanks to the chromecast Chrome
extension so I'll put the link right
below that like button for that if you
want to try it out first with the
portable devices when you run your
chromecast is turned on you'll actually
see a chromecast button on the top of
the YouTube app the Google Play Movies
app the Google Play Music app and
unfortunately those Plus Netflix and
Pandora are the only apps that natively
support chromecast but since the API is
out and now it's brand-new hopefully
we'll see way more apps like Hulu and
Plex and Spotify and even Dropbox and
more showing up with this button so
press that button once and choose your
chromecast TV and the media you were
playing on your mobile device will now
begin to buffer and start playing on
your TV
so your device is now a remote control
for the media on your TV you have all
your playback controls you can view the
cue and add stuff to the cue you can go
ahead and pause and play the media with
the tap of a finger with a very very
tiny delay between the button press and
the action you can go ahead and adjust
the volume if you want you can even
totally exit the app and go do whatever
else you want it to do on your device
while the media continues playing on
your TV because you don't have to have
the app open but if I so go ahead and
show you notification controls in the
notification center which is pretty
sweet on Android I've actually seen a
lot of reviewers and people talking
about the chromecast using a bit of what
I would say bad phrasing or bad word
choice it makes it seem like you are
beaming the content directly from the
device to the TV but that is not what is
going on here what's happening is you're
actually transferring the action from
your device to your TV so the chromecast
has an internet connection of its own so
when you're playing YouTube video on
your phone and tap the chromecast button
the chromecast then looks up the YouTube
video and start streaming it on its own
independent of what your phone is doing
same deal with Google Play Music and
when it starts streaming it's on its own
independent of your phone if you're
listening to a song on your phone's own
internet connection you hit the
chromecast button then your phone tells
the chromecast what song it was
listening to essentially and your
chromecast goes and looks up the song
and pulls it down all by itself and
start playing from there
that's why locally stored media is so
weird right now with the chromecast it's
really not meant for that think of this
as the Nexus Q reloaded Google Play
Movies works the same way hit that cast
button and you're suddenly streaming a
movie directly from the cloud to your TV
the device is just an idle remote for
you to do whatever it wants use open
other applications multitask whatever
it's totally free and that's actually
kind of a nice feature I found out the
quality of the media was also pretty
great I have a 1080p TV here so I know
immediate it and for the first few
seconds of playback of a video sometimes
the videos were a little bit soft but
after a few seconds of buffering it's
sharpened right up to full HD quality
which was nice now for the stuff that's
not natively supported yet there is
always Chrome's extension that allows
for individual tabs streaming through
chromecast so you download the extension
for Chrome pair it up with your TV and
start casting and then you're actually
sending content over your internet
connect
to your TV so this one's a little more
weird if you have a solid connection
then the will it'll be pretty fast
they'll obviously be a slight delay when
scrolling around a web page and you know
sometimes I couldn't see my mouse while
on the TV while casting only on my
laptop screen but then again the quality
here is pretty good it starts off low
quality when the casting is initiating
but after a few seconds it sharpens
right up and you can read whole articles
of text watch full screen videos and
basically browse the web like you would
on your laptop so if you want to show
someone a neat website or an article or
some video or something that's not in
YouTube or Google Play you can just go
ahead and stream your tab cast your tab
over to your TV and start showing people
your internet in that way so that's
pretty cool that you're not restricted
to just supported apps again when that
API rolls out it'll smoke being
supported like everywhere and you won't
have to worry about streaming your tabs
all the time I also tried to stream my
entire desktop and but that actually
ended up crashing I guess that's too
many pixels for it to handle so in the
end that's it that's the Google
chromecast my full review probably could
have been 10 seconds of me just saying
hey it makes your TV smart and it's only
35 bucks buy it you know it's pretty
simple no buy probably an instant buy
for a lot of people who have a TV but
don't have a smart TV and this is
everything the Nexus Q wanted to be but
never really got to be because the price
was just totally wrong so either way
this is a US only product it's really
only available on the Play Store and
from Amazon right now and it's kind of
hard to get which is why it'll be
probably happy to know that I'll be
giving away one of these I have an extra
Google chromecast I'll be giving away
probably the same day that this video
was uploaded so either today or tomorrow
within 24 hours of this upload check out
the Twitter link in the description for
more details on how to get in on that
giveaway it'll be pretty simple and
it'll be international either way that's
it thanks for watching this quick video
review of the chromecast and I'll talk
to you guys in the next one
[Music]